قبل النزال يستعرضون خيولهم ومهاراتهم
استعدادا للمشاركه في لعبه بوسكيشي وتعني
شد الماعز وهي اشهر لعبه افغانيه خنجر
حصان قرغيزي يبلغ ثمنه 40 الف دولار فارسه
عمر بهلوان تعلم اللعبه عن عائلته فوالده
وجده كان لاعبين منذ 50 عاما السابقه
لكن منذ 15 سنه
لديها خيول ممتازه فالخيل الذي يطيع فارس
يعتبر جيدا
صراع على قطعه جلد محشوه بلحم عجل على شكل
ماعز
مصدون نقاط بالهروب بها من
دابه ووضعها في دائره اخرى تسمى دائره
الحلال
مفاجاه في اصابه لاعب تخرجه من ميدان
النزال فالقوه والصمود تتجلى بهذه اللعبه
التاريخيه لدى الافضل
في النهايه تمكن فريق قسما قال من الفوز
بعد جهد كبير في البطوله التي شارك فيها
12 فريقا
الدخول
عبد العزيز سريع
ولايه سمنجاري الشماليه اذن بالبطوله بعد
10 ايام من النزال والتصفيات وهتافات
المشجعين في لعبه يعد تاريخها الى اكثر من
ثمانيه قرون ويفتخر بها الافغان كونها
تشكل رمزا للشجاعه والقوه
مثل صموده هؤلاء اللاعبين حتى صفاره نهايه
المباراه واعلان الفريق الفائز صمدت
البيسكي في افغانستان امام الصراعات
المتتاليه على مر العصور وبقيت اللعبه
الاولى رغم كل الاهوال التي مرت بها
البلاد منذ اكثر من 40 عاما ناصر شديد
الجزيره الجزيره كابول